[Music]
the administration is not enforcing the
immigration laws
it's attracting people and enticing
people to make this very dangerous trek
causing them to lose their lives
that's texas governor greg abbott
demanding action and accountability from
the white house after 53 migrants are
found dead inside a tractor-trailer
former arkansas governor mike huckabee
joins us now governor this is such a
tragedy and you know it's not just the
people migrating to the united states
who are dying it's also the americans
who are are dying because of fentanyl
poisonings that are taking place in this
country and when it does come to the
border issue and the politics of it i
think it's really a game of messaging
and democrats message is that their open
border policies are compassionate
are republicans doing enough to counter
that
i don't think anybody can look at this
horrific scene that unfolded down in
texas this week 53 people died a
miserable painful excruciating and
totally avoidable death
because of the human trafficking that's
happening largely because the policies
that the bite administration is what i
call the mini pearl philosophy the old
country comedian who said y'all come
and that's what the biden administration
has said they have ignored the law and
that's what's significant here if you
don't like a border law you have a right
to go to congress and get it changed you
don't have the right to just ignore it
and pretend it doesn't exist and the
result is
53 people died in that truck
several others are still in critical
condition and may yet die and as you
mentioned carly and this is so important
when people
maybe think that the border crisis stops
at the border it doesn't it goes all
over the country with every death of
fentanyl with every type of human
trafficking where a nine-year-old is
turned into a select sex slave this is
horrible and it's unacceptable and the
joe biden administration like it or not
they own this
speaking of the administration here's
what the borders are vp harris had to
say back to abbott yesterday
how the governor of that state responded
really highlights
part of the problem
because his response there are 50 dead
bodies in his state is to go straight to
politics
instead of dealing with the realities of
the issue
kind of makes you wonder what are the
realities of the issue this feels like
the biggest unforced error of the
administration
i don't know that kamala harris has made
sense of anything that she said in the
past six months it's absolutely hard to
understand
is she just speaking words randomly from
the dictionary or is she trying to make
a point the point she was trying to make
there was lost on me because she was
talking about the realities well the
realities miss this vice president is 53
dead people in the back of a truck
because
your policies and you're in charge of it
joe biden said you're going to be the
czar as you mentioned joey well what
kind of policies
end up letting people just cross the
border at will to be turned into slaves
this is horrible and why we don't
understand that this is not about the
politics of who gets to come this
country welcomes people to migrate we're
a great country because of immigrants
thank god for them but i don't thank god
for the kind of exploitation of human
beings that we're seeing where people
are making millions of dollars
exploiting the most vulnerable and the
poorest people from third world
countries and pretending that they're
going to be escorted to a better life
when they're often escorted to slavery
or their deaths we're hoping you could
translate
for us something that kamala harris said
earlier this week about 2024 take a
listen to this
joe biden is running for re-election and
i will be his ticket mate
full stop cool stop
that's it well governor she issued a
clarification on that saying the
president intends to run and if he does
i will be his ticketmate we will run
together what do you make of this
strange clarification
i think she's trying desperately to hang
on to the job full stop
uh
this is so funny to watch her on one
hand trying to say absolutely we're
going to be there the next day well we
intend to but we're not sure
somebody at the white house told her to
back that
down a little bit and she did
the only thing you can be assured of
with a kamalahara statement is the next
day she's going to make some type of
clarification to it because it didn't
make sense the first day
well with a passage of time sometimes
you need to make those clarifications
governor thank you so much for joining
us this morning you're the best we
appreciate you having you on
you bet thank you so much you too